Council on Foreign Relations Meeting
Subject: Recent Developments in Mexico, Mexico-U.S.
Relations and Mexico's Role on the International
Stage
Speaker: Felipe Calderon, President of Mexico
Presider: Carla A. Hills, Chairman and CEO,
Hills &
Company; Co-Chairman, Board of Directors,
Council on
Foreign Relations
Location: Council On Foreign Relations, Washington,
D.C.
Time: 8:59 a.m. EDT
Date: Monday, September 24, 2012
.STX
(C) COPYRIGHT 2012, FEDERAL NEWS SERVICE,
INC., 1120 G STREET NW; SUITE 990; WASHINGTON,
DC - 20005, USA.
ALL RIGHTS RESERVED.
ANY REPRODUCTION, REDISTRIBUTION OR RETRANSMISSION
IS EXPRESSLY PROHIBITED.
UNAUTHORIZED REPRODUCTION, REDISTRIBUTION
OR RETRANSMISSION CONSTITUTES A MISAPPROPRIATION
UNDER APPLICABLE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW, AND
FEDERAL NEWS SERVICE, INC.
RESERVES THE RIGHT TO PURSUE ALL REMEDIES
AVAILABLE TO IT IN RESPECT TO SUCH MISAPPROPRIATION.
FEDERAL NEWS SERVICE, INC.
IS A PRIVATE FIRM AND IS NOT AFFILIATED WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
NO COPYRIGHT IS CLAIMED AS TO ANY PART OF
THE ORIGINAL WORK PREPARED BY A UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT OFFICER OR EMPLOYEE AS PART OF
THAT PERSON'S OFFICIAL DUTIES.
FOR INFORMATION ON SUBSCRIBING TO FNS, PLEASE
CALL 202-347-1400 OR EMAIL INFO@FEDNEWS.COM.
THIS IS A RUSH TRANSCRIPT.
-------------------------
>> CARLA A. HILLS: Welcome to this Council
on Foreign Relations meeting.
We are so very honored to have the president
of Mexico, Felipe Calderon.
And before we get started, let me say that
this meeting is on the record, and it is being
telecommunicated to New York by video conference.
So we beg you, turn off all wireless devices
-- phones, BlackBerrys -- not to vibrate but
off, really off.
And as it is customary to preserve the maximum
time for our conversation with the president,
my introduction will be undiplomatically short.
You have the president's resume in your papers
that were given to you as you entered the
hall, so let me simply say that President
Calderon, the youngest of five boys, earned
a bachelor's degree in law, master's degree
in economics and a master's degree in public
administration at the John Kennedy School
up at Harvard University.
He became a supporter of the party for -- the
National Action Party, PAN, early on, becoming
the president of the youth organization.
In the late '90s he became its president.
And before the 2006 election, as president
of Mexico, he had served as a deputy in Mexico's
federal chamber of deputies and as secretary
of energy.
He will leave office in December, remembered
as the president who built the most universities,
96; the 16,000 kilometers of highways; a bridge
that connects Mexico's two costs, providing
faster access and therefore more efficient
trade; and the passage of the first employment
act, which provides incentives for companies
to hire people just entering the workforce.
He also faced the daunting challenge of the
violence spawned by the drug cartels that
left 50,000 people dead.
A poll taken just this past August showed
his approval rating above 64 percent.
We are so honored to have the President of
Mexico here with us.
And, Mr. President, we welcome you to this
podium and look forward to your remarks.
[Applause.]
>> PRESIDENT FELIPE CALDERON: Good morning.
Carla, thank you for your words.
Well, it's an honor to be here today at the
Council on Foreign Relations.
For more than 90 years, this institution has
been at the forefront of analysis to understand
the challenges and foreign policy choices
facing the United States and the world.
Six years ago, at my first -- (inaudible)
-- address, I told the Mexican people that
it was possible to transform Mexico.
I said that we could transform Mexico into
a more prosperous nation with a dynamic and
competitive economy.
I said that we could be a fair society with
more opportunities for everyone.
I was convinced, as I am now, that we could
transform Mexico into a safer nation with
a strong rule of law.
I can tell you today that we have made great
strides and have put Mexico on track to making
this vision a reality.
I would like to share some reflections on
how we have transformed Mexico into a stronger
nation and a better neighbor.
Let me start by talking about the transformation
of the Mexican economy.
As you know, we had to confront the worst
global economic crisis in living memory.
Mexico was particularly vulnerable to this
shock because of our ties to the American
economy and the consumption in this country
which was -- which was the epicenter of the
crisis three years ago.
Fortunately, we took the necessary measures
to prevent this crisis from becoming a major
catastrophe.
In doing so, we were guided by three basic
concepts: financial discipline, economic freedom
and increased competitiveness.
And this strategy has paid off to the country.
First, Mexico has preserved sound economic
fundamentals.
Many countries put in place counter-cyclical
measures to protect their economies from the
shock waves or the financial turmoil, and
we did as well.
In Mexico, we implemented counter-cyclical
measures to save jobs and keep our industries
afloat.
For instance, we created specific programs
to save jobs in export-oriented industries.
We reached an agreement with the unions and
the companies in the sense that as long the
worker accept to earn one-third less on his
salary, and the company accept to pay one-third
of his salary, the government -- the federal
government accepted to pay the other third
part of his salary, and in that way, we save
more than half a million jobs right in the
middle of the crisis in export-oriented industries.
We increased government transfer to the poorest
and established a temporary jobs program.
In doing so, we created another half a million
temporary works for the people.
And of course, all this cost a lot of money.
Our public deficit rates levels of almost
4 percent of GDP in 2010, and we understood
that today's deficit are tomorrow's taxes,
and the market always punish fiscal lack of
responsibility.
That is why expanding public deficit to stimulate
economy is a one-shot deal, and we understood
that.
Once you do it, you have to take measures
to rebuild your financial equilibriums.
The big mistake made by many economies during
the crisis was to forget that you can use
public deficit, like this, once.
But if you try to use it on a regular basis,
you will face, sooner or later, tremendous
problems to finance such deficit and that's
exactly what is happening with several economies
in Europe right now.
That is why we put in place an exit strategy
to regain a fiscal balance quickly, and this
strategy included several painful measures:
for instance, increasing tax revenues, reducing
public expenditures, promoting the structural
reforms and an aggressive deregulation program.
We also shut down a very inefficient energy
company, Luz y Fuerza del Centro, which saved
the government more than $5 billion a year
in subsidies.
And thanks to fiscal discipline, public debt
is at a historically low level, and our foreign
reserves are above $160 billion, more than
twice the amount of our total foreign debt,
and we have maintained the lowest inflation
levels of the past seven decades.
Another important factor behind Mexico's stability
is our financial sector.
While in the U.S. the crisis started in the
financial markets and in the banking sectors,
Mexico, the financial sector was not part
of the problem, but part of the solution.
Thanks to the improvements in regulations,
Mexican banks have a capitalization index
of 16 percent, almost double that the recommendation
of Basel, and well above the countries such
as China, England or even the U.S.
Second, we maintain our strong commitment
to free trade.
This is easier said than done.
A lot of you remember at every G-20 summit,
one of the useful paragraphs in the final
declaration always say that all countries
pledge to refrain from adopting protectionist
measures.
All the countries used to say, we reject protectionism.
And time and again, 15 out of the 20 members
put such measures into effect in the following
days.
Only Mexico -- only Mexico started to reduce
tariffs right in the middle of the crisis.
Mexico, on the contrary, has reduced tariffs
from 12 percent 4 percent on average and entered
into new free trade agreements, such as the
Alliance of the Pacific with Colombia, Chile
and Peru.
And a few months ago, Mexico joined the Trans-Pacific
Partnership, TPP, negotiations.
This will give Mexican trade the biggest boost
since NAFTA came into effect.
Third, we work hard to increase our competitiveness.
Despite the crisis, we boosted investment
in infrastructure.
To give you an idea, the 20,000 kilometers
of road we have built and repaired are more
or less equal to the distance between the
North and South Poles.
We also doubled our bet in our own people
by building -- 96 was the figure last year
-- today is 140 new public universities.
And today more than 113,000 engineers graduate
each year in Mexico, a higher figure than
in Germany, Canada or Brazil.
And what are the results of these strategies?
Today Mexico exports more manufacturing goods
than all the countries of Latin America and
the Caribbean combined, including Brazil.
Mexico now accounts for almost 13 percent
of U.S. imports of manufactured goods, and
in 2005, Mexico's share was below 10 percent.
Ten years ago about 90 percent of the country's
export went to the U.S.
And last year that figure fell to 76 percent.
When I took office six years ago, Mexico was
the ninth-largest car exporter to the world,
and today we are the fourth-largest car exporter.
Mexico is now the second-largest importer
of American products in the world, and we
buy more U.S. goods than the rest of Latin
America combined, more than Japan and China
together.
Indeed, this deep transformation of the Mexican
economy is of critical importance to the economic
success of the United States as well.
But if you -- if we want to guarantee our
mutual prosperity in the long run, we need
to do more.
We need to maintain North American competitive
edge over other regions, and the key to get
there is more integration, not less.
NAFTA was a very important step, but our economies
must work to deepen our ties fuller and build
on this foundation.
A second deep transformation that is occurring
in Mexico: that we are becoming a middle-class
nation.
Of course, this does not mean that we have
ended poverty once and for all.
But it means is that the average Mexican families
now has a much better quality of life than
it did a decade ago.
According to the scholars Rubio and De la
Calle, in the last years Mexican families
have improved their access to housing, cars,
durable goods such as home appliances and
computers, health and education services and
entertainment, all of which are staples of
the global middle class.
Let me -- let me give you, for example, how
public policies have helped to these ends.
First, universal health coverage.
For my government, access to health services
for everyone is a fundamental human right.
This is why we made an unprecedented commitment
to improve health care that has resulted in
a historical achievement: universal health
coverage.
And doing so, we have built more than 1,000
new hospitals or clinics and rebuilt more
than 2,000 more.
Second, expanded education opportunities.
Today, for the first time, every child in
Mexico can attend elementary school, and we
have expanded university enrollment from 24
[percent] to 34 percent of young people at
superior -- at superior level.
Third, the stronger social programs.
We have in place strong support network programs,
which include conditional cash transfer to
help the poorest families, Oportunidades,
pensions for the elderly in poor communities,
Setenta y Mas, and day care centers in urban
areas for working mothers attended by other
mothers in town.
And fourth, more home ownership.
Home ownership is a yardstick of economic
performance and of the strength of the middle
class.
Thanks to a combination of a stable economy,
a solid financial system and government-supported
programs, in the last six years, more than
5 million Mexican families were able to buy
their own house at record figures.
The improvement of living conditions in Mexico
is having a positive effect in the continent.
For instance, according to a Pew Hispanic
Center analysis, net migration from Mexico
to the U.S. has steadily decreased in recent
years, and finally reached zero in 2010, and
probably became a net output from the U.S.
in 2011.
Of course, can be explained by the increase
in border security and the economic downturn
in the United States, but there is a strong
argument that better opportunity for Mexico
have also been a key factor for this phenomenon.
So by first time ever, net migration to the
U.S. is zero on average.
However, we must not forget that migration
is a natural phenomenon for two countries
that has been going -- has been going on for
as long as the United States and Mexico have
existed and will continue to happen naturally.
Our economies are clearly complementary.
As a labor-intensive economy, we have the
ability to supply a capital-intensive economy
such as the U.S. with qualified and hardworking
Mexican workers.
This is why I believe that an agenda for the
future should continue to focus, on ensuring
that migration takes place in a legal, secure
and orderly way, but that the U.S. economy
is to strengthen, and Mexicans do not have
to die while trying to get a job.
(Inaudible) -- from the values we share as
neighbors and partners to find solutions to
these common problems, and help the many workers
who today live in the shadows of the society.
And I want to take this opportunity to recognize,
once again, President Obama's decision begin
to give some young immigrants the opportunity
to continue contributing to the strength and
vitality of the United States.
It's a positive move for both countries that
I applaud.
And now I want to talk to you about the third
fundamental change initiated due to my time
in office: the struggle to consolidate the
rule of law in Mexico.
I know this is an issue that has captured
headlines in the United States and around
the world, and it has been one of the main
challenges my administration has had to face.
Over the years, criminal organization grew
in power until they became stronger than the
local authorities in several places in some
parts of the country, and even before my term
started, violence and crime were major concerns
across many cities in Mexico.
But we decided to face the problem head-on,
with the full force of the state.
We implemented a comprehensive strategy with
three main components.
First, to confront the violent criminal organizations
and to support overwhelmed local governments,
we deployed the federal police and the armed
forces, giving the states and municipalities
time and room for maneuver in order to rebuild
and strengthen their law enforcement agencies,
especially police corps at local level.
Second, and more important, we have strengthened
the federal police by increasing the size
of the force from 6(,000) to 36,000 officers.
They are also better trained, better debriefed
and better paid.
We are helping the states to do the same.
And we are vetting any top officers in federal
police and passing through a very important
and particular set of tests for new members.
And we are moving to a more transparent and
efficient judicial system based on oral and
open trials, just like the one you have here
in the United States.
Third, we are investing heavily in education
and health to tackle the social causes of
crime, opening rehabilitation centers for
addicts and rebuilding public spaces like
parks, soccer fields and community centers.
I have to say that Mexico has not been alone
in this security effort.
We have found in the Obama administration
a spirit of renewed cooperation to face common
problems under the principle of shared responsibilities.
But there is no doubt that much more must
be done, particularly when I -- when it comes
to monitoring the financial operations of
criminals' organizations in the U.S. and reducing
American demand for drugs.
We need to have a coordinated on both initiatives
to get to the root of this problem which is
increasing demand for illegal drugs in the
U.S. As long as this market continues growing,
money will keep flowing to the pocket of the
criminals.
Of course, the best way will be to reduce
illicit drug demand in the U.S.
But frankly speaking, that is not possible.
All alternative solutions must be considered
to curb the massive profits of criminal organizations.
That includes market alternatives that prevent
drug trafficking from causing so much violence
and death.
There is another problem that has become vital
for the security of Mexico and many other
nations: halting the uncontrolled sale of
assault weapons to criminal organizations.
Unlimited access to assault weapons in the
U.S. is a key factor in the current strength
of criminal organizations.
You can see a clear correlation between the
moment in which the assault weapons ban expire
here in the U.S. in 2004, and that is exactly
the moment in which the violence in Mexico
started to grow.
And it is clear that the more weapons to have
available, more violence of homicide you will
have in any part of the world.
You can see the same phenomenon, whether in
Africa or Central America, during civil wars
and other phenomenons (ph).
And that is exactly what is happening in Mexico
as well.
During my term, we have seized more than 150,000
guns and weapons.
And more than 80 percent of them were sold
in an American gun shop.
And there is nine gun shop in the border with
Mexico per each Wal-Mart in that city.
For Mexico it is absolutely unfair -- unfair
and offensive that so many lives have lost
because of the -- of this business or proceed
to (swell ?) the profits of the arms industry.
It is possible to think in a regulation that
what established here in the U.S. in the '90s,
the Assault Weapons Ban, is a problem that
has to be addressed if you want to build a
safer North America.
And finally, I would like to talk about a
profound transformation in our role in the
world.
Mexico is no longer a spectator in global
affairs.
We are becoming a nation committed to actively
participating in the solutions of global challenges.
For instance, the COP-16 meeting that Mexico
hosted in 2010 was a milestone in the global
fight against climate change.
The agreements reached in Cancun were an important
step towards more effective international
climate finance mechanism such as the Green
Climate Fund, a Mexican proposal (tying ?) resources
to adaptation and mitigation measures around
the world.
We are also -- we are also the first country
in Latin America to chair the G-20 meeting
in June.
During the leaders' meeting in Los Cabos this
year, we reached important agreements such
as the capital injections of over $455 billion
to the International Monetary Fund.
Moreover, the Los Cabos action plan for growth
established commitments to deal with the eurozone
crisis and to strengthen sustainable economic
growth.
Dear friends, ladies and gentlemen, Mexicans
are working to build a better nation, stronger
and safer country where the rule of law prevails,
as well as more competitive economy and fairer
society.
If Mexico continues on this path of transformation
in the future, it is on the threshold of becoming
the prosperous nation our citizens wish for
and deserve.
This day and age, however, no nation can succeed
without the support of its strategic partners.
The more Mexico and the United States cooperate,
the more we can build a future our people
rightfully demand.
Both the U.S. and Mexico, with our new presidential
terms this year, if both our economies are
well on the road to health, the window of
opportunity to strengthen the bilateral relationship,
the upcoming administrations in Mexico have
a solid foundation on which to build a stronger
future, and I wish my successor all the best.
If I look at how far we have come, I have
never been more confident that Mexico and
the United States will continue deepening
our integration and strengthening our strategic
partnership as we face up the challenges of
the 21st century.
It has been a pleasure to stay here, and of
course I will attend all your questions.
Thank you very much.
[Applause.]
>> HILLS: Mr. President, we thank you for
those very fine and fulsome remarks.
I would like to ask you, in view of your interest
in open trade and what you've accomplished,
what do you see as the prospects for United
States, Mexico and Canada in the Trans-Pacific
Partnership?
>> CALDERON: Well, the point is we must to
understand how important is that for our people
and our economies.
And if we can get this agreement, we will
connect our economies to the most prosperous
region in the world at least in two decades.
That is the idea.
My concern is that there are a lot of protectionist
spirits, I can say that, in local politics
-- the same as, I suppose, in the United States
and Mexico.
So a lot of people believe that more protected
you are the more prosperity you will have.
I mean, it's exactly the other way around.
But for any politician, it's easier to talk
about protection and talk about borders and
barriers than to talk about real freedom,
which you and your constituents will compete.
And that is a serious concern.
And the problem is the protectionism, the
gulf that appears exactly in the middle of
the crisis.
So what can be the chance to move forward
in the TPP?
I have -- one problem that I'm seeing that
the day for a real advance in this process
was delayed one more year.
So but I listen in the APEC meeting if there
will be an agreement this year, which was
exactly what we were expecting.
And it's necessary to regain momentum in local
societies to reach the goal we are looking
for.
And probably the political campaign hurts
Mexico, but especially the presidential campaign
here will be a temporary obstacle for TPP.
But once the Americans decide this important
question, I hope that we can move together,
common efforts in order to get the TPP probably
next year.
And that measure will open big opportunities
for our trade economy.
>> HILLS: You mentioned that the North American
Free Trade Agreement was fine and that we
should build on it.
A lot of people have thought that the three
governments could do more to create cohesion
and competitiveness in the Western hemisphere.
Is that possible or are there disputes between
us -- like maybe the tomato dispute -- that
hold us back from accomplishing what we might
aspire to for creating new opportunities?
>> CALDERON: It will be a permanent battle,
if I can say that.
And first, let me congratulate you, personally,
for this tremendous achievement which has
a historical dimension, the NAFTA, several
years ago.
And I think it is possible and it is necessary
to build upon the NAFTA.
In particular, we need to do several things
at the same time.
One, we need to improve the infrastructure
at the border.
So there is a lot of bottleneck on both sides.
I mean, if we are able to rearrange to increase
the competitiveness of the border itself then
the infrastructure will be great.
Second, we should understand that the NAFTA
will provide a lot of opportunities, not only
for Mexican workers and providers but also
for American workers and providers.
Actually, there is serious research in which
we can demonstrate the real benefits in terms
of jobs and personal income for any one of
the states here.
So we need to explain to the people what are
those benefits.
But again, the problem that free trade will
face at any time, and in particular in electoral
times, is protectionism.
And that is the case of the tomato.
So it seems like this election is so competitive
and the idea is that the tomato could vote
and could pick the president -- [laughter]
-- and then look like -- incredible that I
can say that, no?
[Laughter.]
But let me tell you that Mexican tomato is
very good for American consumers -- [laughter]
-- are cheaper.
And if you are looking for how to improve
the economy, you need to open the border to
the Mexican tomato, not the other way around.
[Laughter.]
But if the tomatoes are going to select the
next president, I think this country is in
problems.
[Laughter.]
>> HILLS: Let me ask this last question before
I go to the audience.
We want to keep protections down.
And unfortunately, they are going up.
You mentioned, though, the unfortunate nature
of the tomato problem.
What are the prospects of opening energy so
that the United States and Mexico could collaborate
on developing on a really necessary asset
for our economies?
>> CALDERON: Well, that's a important question.
I think that today there is a wind of opportunity
to open a little bit, at least, the energy
sector in Mexico.
And I say this understanding that it's absolutely
necessary because today we have a new challenge
and a new opportunity as well.
Let me talk, for instance, about Pemex or
any public company or owned-state company.
Its managers are looking for the way in which
they can get more benefits with less resources,
like any other company, probably.
But in this particular case -- as long as
the technology moving ahead, and now technology
are -- it's allowing us to get natural gas
in particular, shale gas, a very cheap way,
the price of natural gas in the North American
region going down dramatically.
And that is good for industry because it means
cheaper energy for any industry and any economy.
You -- probably you can remember that 15 or
10 years ago the price of natural gas was
a serious obstacle for the economy.
I remember when I was secretary of energy,
the price of natural gas was, like, 12 (dollars)
or $15, and today the price, probably 2 (dollars)
or $3.
So that is an amazing opportunity for the
region.
That means that Mexico could be even more
competitive, because now we have a very high
competitiveness in manufacturing sector.
We have very well-trained workers.
We have more infrastructure.
We have free trade with the United States
and with other nations.
It's a lot of, a set of very many competitive
aspects.
Plus today we will have cheaper natural gas.
So we have everything to win.
That is the opportunity.
But the problem is for Pemex managers with
very few public resources who'll decide what
will be the most profitable activity for the
company.
You need -- you need to decide either to invest
natural gas with very short marginal revenues
and with a lot of risk because you need a
lot of technology and massive investment,
or to invest in oil, which you could cost
probably 20 (dollars), $30 per barrel, and
you can sell that barrel at more than $100.
Clearly, Pemex could go towards the oil, even
in the very deep Gulf of Mexico.
By the way, we discovered last month a new
research, a new field, deepwater -- the Gulf
of Mexico.
It's the first time Mexico had such kind of
discover, at least in 40 years.
And if we compare the forecast of that, that
discover could imply to double our -- (inaudible)
-- in a very short time.
But let me go back to natural gas.
So we need to think how can we open the natural
gas sector in order to promote massive investment,
and with that we can get more job creation,
more energy efficiency, more natural gas at
very low prices, which means more competitiveness
for industry, cheaper electricity for people
and a lot of benefits.
But in order to do so, we need to change the
legal framework of this matter.
Now, why I am saying that there is a window
of opportunity?
Because I do believe on that, President-elect
Mr. Pena believes that it is necessary to
reform the energy sector as well.
Look, you have these political willness to
do something -- energy sector, there is a
window of opportunity.
So what is going to happen?
On my side, there is all the political willness
that is required.
>> HILLS: Well, we'll go to the audience.
I know that there are questions here.
And I would ask, if you're called upon, to
please state your name and affiliation and
wait for the microphone to come to you.
On the aisle there, Richard.
Is there a mic there?
>> QUESTIONER: Thank you.
Richard Downey from the Center for Hemispheric
Defense Studies.
Mr. President, thank you for your remarks,
and thank you for being here with us at the
Council on Foreign Relations.
One of the hallmarks of your administration
was, in my view, the very courageous decision
to confront organized crime.
And you talked a little bit about the strategy,
the comprehensive strategy to do that.
President-elect Enrique Pena Nieto has talked
about making changes to your strategy.
Have you talked to him, or perhaps has your
team talked to his transition team, about
how to make continuity and not lose many of
the gains that you've made during your six
years in office, the way ahead?
Thank you.
>> CALDERON: Thank you.
Now, first let me express my gratitude because
you framed the question exactly in the way
you did.
So it -- we are fighting organized crime,
which is not exactly the same that -- "war
on drugs" is the expression coined here in
the United States several decades ago.
And it's absolutely -- not absolutely, but
it's different.
So our aim is rule of law.
So we have not some kind of obsession against
drugs itself.
It's rule of law which must prevail in the
country, and according to that, we need to
enforce the law; we need to fight organized
crime.
And organized crime is linked with several
criminal activities -- of course, drugs, but
not only and probably not mainly drugs, but
also human traffic and also weapons traffic
and also -- [inaudible] -- and kidnapping
and a lot of very dark activities.
Second, I respect the decision of president-elect
on any matters, including the strategy for
security in the country.
Now, let me tell you that I was following
all of the electoral campaign.
A lot of candidates talked about -- they were
framing the expression in this way: We'll
continue the effort, we will continue the
strategy, but we will make some changes -- [audio
break] -- and any candidate go exactly the
same in another way.
When any candidate was asked, what could be
those changes, at least myself, I could not
see clearly what were going to be those differences.
So from my understanding -- for instance,
one expression is we will use more intelligence
and less force.
That is correct, but what is what is exactly
what we are doing, we are improving the information
and intelligence capacity of the public agencies.
Actually, we build probably the state of the
art center for intelligence for federal police
right now.
We are using -- I told a rumor, a conversation
I had with President Bush when we were talking
about the -- we were framing the Merida Initiative
at the very beginning of my administration.
I was trying to explain exactly that.
We need more intelligence, so we need any
kind of instruments and technology in order
to be able to prosecute criminals and prevent
crime.
Trying to explain that, I told President Bush,
well, have you ever seen this TV show "24"
with Jack Bauer and so on?
[Laughter.]
Because I want all the instruments of this
guy.
[Laughter.]
And that is exactly what we are doing.
So it's quite interesting to see the center
of Federal Police -- several centers we are
building, and the same with the Army, and
the same with the PDR.
So we are improving intelligence.
Actually, we are sharing intelligence with
the U.S. more than ever.
That could be one change, but exactly in the
same track with this.
Other could be -- what else?
We will be more preventive than the reactive.
But in any case, you need to be very active
in any field, no?
And I make some kind of a contrast, or I use
some task force I come in from health services,
no?
Of course, we understand that even in health
services, you need to be -- to be more preventive,
and we are applying a little programs in order
to reduce the obesity in child, for instance,
and the people.
But once you have -- (inaudible) -- with diabetes,
you need to apply him a very reactive treatment.
Otherwise, we will -- he will die, no?
But that is exactly what is happening in Mexico.
Of course we need -- and actually, we did
a lot of universities.
Building 140 new public universities from
greenfield is not exactly only a question
of education.
It's a question of opportunities for young
people.
And I understand that the day in which Mexico
reach full coverage for any young people in
the country, we could solve a lot of the security
problem.
So you need to be preventive, yes, and that
is the reason why we are creating education
opportunities for young people.
But at the same time, you need to face the
criminals in the street.
You cannot allow that the criminals take the
control of one city, to substitute the authority,
because there is this -- the criminals, the
organized crime is doing some kind of a takeover
of the authority in one city.
They reach to a town or even a city, they
threat or bribe the local authority, including
police corps, so they become the new authority
there.
So they start to apply their own law, they
started to collect their own taxes, and they
started to use public force.
Actually, there is not other public force
than they public force.
So in that sense, it's a challenge to the
state.
Now, you are federal government.
Are you going to wait in which you can build
all the universities in that town, and can
you wait several years until (all the kids
back ?) to those universities?
How many years is going to take that, and
what is going to happen with the people during
those 10 or 20 or 30 years?
So you need to defend the families.
There is no option to act.
And that is the problem, I think, that Mexico
suffered a lot, because this lack of action
of the government allow the criminals to take
over a lot of regions.
And it's not limited -- that is not only a
question that the government started fighting
the criminals and that then the violence went
up.
Of course there is a relationship, yes.
But frankly speaking, I do believe that the
violence will be there even without the action
of the government.
Why?
Because we are now in the face of a new criminal
phenomenon.
In the past, last century, what was the core
business of the criminals?
Narco-traffic.
Even -- that is the -- what the words mean.
Traffic -- the U.S., and that's it.
And it's a problem of calculus, if I can say
that.
It's only one dimension.
If you think in a line crossing from the Pacific
sea to the American border, it's one line,
one highway and one point -- single point
in the border.
But what happen in the last two decades?
The criminals who start to think in another
business additional to narco-traffic, which
is drug -- the retail drug -- retailing in
Mexico, which is different why?
How many people do you need in order to cross
one ton on cocaine -- of cocaine to United
States?
I don't know, 10 people?
Twenty?
Maybe 50?
Maybe 100?
OK.
But how many people do you need in order to
distribute 1 million bags of one gram of cocaine,
which is the same ton of cocaine?
You will need hundreds or maybe thousand of
people -- a lot of people distributing.
It's absolutely different business.
And upon that, you need to think that in the
old business, if I can say that, they only
need to care about one line towards the United
States.
But if they are starting to go into the retailing
business, they need to cover the whole territory.
That's like any retailing.
Think about Coca-Cola -- (inaudible) or think
about PepsiCo.
It's exactly the same.
They are trying to cover a territory.
And in order to cover a territory, they started
to clash, to shock one each other.
And this disputing over territory is the origin
of violence; it's not the action of the government
itself.
In other words, when our economies have started
to grow -- for instance -- (inaudible) -- Mexican
income per capita went up from $2,000 a year
to more than $10,000 a year today.
And that implies that Mexican market has started
to be a very important consumption market
for vehicles, for households, for whatever,
including drugs.
So they started to see our society as a market
as well.
And then they started to diversify their activity
from only exporting, if I can say that, to
distributing.
And in this change, they started to fight
each other for the territories.
And that clash, that battle explains 80 percent
of the violence, probably, because it's a
battle between the Zetas against the Pacifico;
or now the Zetas split up, so now it's the
Zetas against they -- their old allies, which
is the Gulfo.
And they are clashing each other.
And today probably there is another fight
inside the Zetas itself.
So the problem is this expansion.
Now, the question was very simple -- [chuckles]
-- but I'm sorry for my answer.
[Laughter.]
I use -- I use the opportunity only.
But let me tell you, I do believe that next
administration -- at least exactly what they
are saying -- they are going to continue the
effort.
And I think they have the right and the duty,
I suppose, to analyze another alternatives.
Now, let me be honest.
You really want to think about a real -- another
alternative?
I cannot see any one different from to think
about the regulation of drugs in the global
market, starting here in the U.S.
That is reason why I say if we are not able
or you are not able to reduce the demand for
drugs in a dramatic way, you need to think
in different alternatives.
And you have the duty to analyze any other
alternatives in order to stop the flow of
money towards the hands of the criminals.
And that implies to analyze even market alternatives
for that, because if you want to talk about
the real different way to do these things,
that is the only one.
Or the other is to return the power to the
criminals, to say, I won't fight with them
anymore.
Please be my guest.
Take -- you like this government?
Please take this government.
You like that city?
It's nice, so -- [laughter] -- I like it so
much, but take it; I won't fight.
You cannot say that like a government, because
it's the first duty -- the first duty of any
government is to preserve the right of the
security of the families.
And that is very top duty.
Believe me, I know that.
But you must do that.
>> HILLS: Yes, please.
Microphone.
>> QUESTIONER: [In Spanish.]
My name is Christopher Broughton; I work with
the Millennium Challenge Corporation.
I have a related question, and that is the
movement of arms and bulk cash to Mexico from
the United States.
What has your administration done to strengthen
Mexico's own border security to prevent these
illegal flows?
Thank you.
>> CALDERON: Well, talking about weapons,
we are siezing a lot, no?
One hundred and fifty thousand guns and weapons
in five years is a lot.
And we are establishing some kind of controls
on the highways.
We are working really hard on that field.
Talking about stemming illegal cash, that's
more difficult for us.
For instance, we were estimating that three
years ago -- two years ago, only in the banking
sector we detected, like -- we could be, like,
14 billion (dollars) -- 14 billions (dollars)
a year, which it was dollars that we needed
to send back to the United States coming from
the banking system.
And we had not cleared the sources of those
dollars, no?
So that made us to take a lot of measures.
For instance, we forbidden a lot of cash transfers
in dollars in Mexico.
And of course, I got a lot of reject, especially
in border towns.
I need to imply a lot of political -- (inaudible)
-- for my own party, but it was necessary.
And we are reducing dramatically the kind
of not well-explained dollars in the banking
system probably towards 4 billion (dollars)
-- 4 billion (dollars) a year today, so we
are reducing that part.
The other, I presented to the Congress a bill
in order to regulate laundry money.
Well, probably that was, like, two or three
years ago.
(Inaudible.)
We are waiting one chamber of the other.
>> QUESTIONER: (Inaudible) -- the Senate?
>> CALDERON: Today it's in the Senate.
Probably tomorrow will be again in the Chamber
of Deputies, and after tomorrow will be again
in the Senate, but we are expecting an approval
from the -- well, secretly what I hope, and
there is a new session and a new legislation
in the Congress.
Actually I really appreciate that there are
four senators here with me today from different
political parties.
And I think that there is a very good chance
that we can finally an approval on this very
important law in order to fight laundry money.
There are a lot of interests against the law.
For instance, we are asking to the people,
you cannot pay in cash.
For instance, when you buy a house, you need
to pay by a check, which is obvious of my
understanding, a lot of things, but some people
don't like that.
[Chuckles.]
But it's absolutely necessary.
>> HILLS: I think we have time for one more
question.
Let me come to this side of the room.
Yes, please, the -- wait for the mic.
>> QUESTIONER: Margaret Daly Hayes of Evidence
Based Research.
Thank you very much, Mr. President, for your
very encouraging remarks about progress in
Mexico.
You are very proud of opening a large number
of universities.
Can you talk a bit about what Mexico is doing,
needs to do, to expand and improve primary
and secondary education in order to enhance
competitiveness?
Thank you.
>> CALDERON: That is very, very important,
but let me talk about what we did.
We reached an agreement with a very important
player, which is the union of teachers.
Union of teachers is a small organization
with probably 1.5 million members in the country.
[Laughter.]
And we reached an agreement in order to improve
the quality of the education.
There are several measures that we agreed
and that were -- those were first, in the
past, a post of teacher was decided by a finger
point, either the union or the governor.
Today for any post of teacher, any position
of teacher, it's decided by a contest between
teachers.
So today you want to get a position as teacher,
you need to compete with other teachers in
order to select the best of them.
And that is a (structural ?) reforming education.
Of course, it's a long way to do that, but
there is almost 100,000 new teachers appointed
in that way -- and does imply a very painful
process.
For instance, we saw several strikes of teachers
in several states, but we, that measure is
on track and it's a good one.
Second, we are establishing an -- (inaudible)
-- waiting process for students and for teachers
as well.
And of course, there are a lot of -- a lot
of resistance for that.
But finally, we got special exams in order
to analyze the level of the teacher.
And we are explaining, it's not a questions
of remove that teacher; it's a question of
we need to see your weakness in order to help
you to improve your capacities as teacher.
Third, we improve the infrastructure in the
schools.
It's not a matter of federal government, by
the way, because let me tell you, education,
as health, is a matter of local level of government
since the '90s.
However, we understood that local government,
probably they have not enough money or they
have another priority different from improve
the quality of the schools, elementary schools.
So we started to rebuild, you know, the window,
the basketball field, the bathrooms for girls
and so on.
And in that sense we have rebuilt 50,000 elementary
schools, very small public works, but we are
doing so.
Fourth, we are establishing a new system of
payments to the teachers because we are introducing
economic incentives.
So if you are teacher, the more your students
improve, the more salary you earn.
So in that sense, we are paying in terms of
the quality.
(Inaudible) -- a very small piece of the salary,
but it's improving.
And finally, we reached last year another
very important reform in which so-called Carrera
Magisterial was mainly oriented to pay to
the teachers in order to -- how many seminars
you could have.
For instance, well, I don't want to make some
examples of what kind of course they were
taking, but today, 50 percent of the Carrera
Magisterial, which is very linked with the
money they receive, is still 50 percent depends
on the improvement of your own students according
to the exams we are doing year after year.
Now, one outcome could be, for instance, the
PISA test.
In six years we establish a goal in the -- in
PISA test, and we are reaching, we overcome,
we surpassed our goal in 2009.
And probably we did the same this year, especially
in math.
Mexican students were the students that advanced
the most in PISA exam, in particularly in
math, in 70 -- in 65 countries.
Of course, Mexico is probably still today
one of the last countries unfortunately on
that.
But we are advancing a lot, in particular
in math.
And we are measuring that in our own exams.
For instance, the Enlasse (ph) -- it's an
evaluation program we have last year to this
year.
(Inaudible) -- our goal was to reach 40 percent
of good at -- excellent students.
We overcome that goal in that sense in math.
We are not doing the same, unfortunately,
in Spanish.
So we need to improve on that.
Now, talking about the challenges, I admit
that this is probably one of the most demanding
challenge for Mexico today.
I mean, it's absolutely necessary to do much
more in terms of quality of education.
And you need to get more cooperation coming
from teachers unions.
The paradox is there are two kinds of teachers
unions.
One has a lot of bad practices, if I can say
that, or bad reputation.
But the other one could be worse.
[Laughter.]
So one is a lot of things that we need to
improve -- and that is, for instance, a new
bill I presented to the Congress last month
in order to reform the labor law, to open
to transparency the finances of the union,
and to stop this direct vote and universal
vote in the union and so on.
But there is another group -- another union
more radical.
They refuse exams.
They take the control even of the payroll
of the workers.
So the -- there are some governments in Mexico
that they need to give the money to the union
teachers and the union pays the salaries according
to its own criteria.
So unfortunately it's my own state, Michoacan,
but it's -- that's a probably in that.
>> HILLS: Mr. President, we could go on all
morning.
We really do thank you for your presence,
but also your excellent, wide-ranging remarks.
[Applause.]
Let me make a request -- let me make a request
of the audience, would you please out of courtesy
stay seated for just one minute and a half
so the president can exit with his party and
get to his next appointment on time -- just
a minute and half.
>> CALDERON: Don't worry -- [inaudible, laughter].
>> HILLS: You have to run fast.
Thank you so much.
[Applause.]
####
®FCŻEND
®FLŻ